MAX SALTONSTALL: My
name's Max Saltonstall,
and I'm happy to be here
with the Serial Box writers.
I want you to introduce
yourselves, but also tell me
what are you writing right now.
MAX GLADSTONE: Hi,
I'm Max Gladstone.
I write fantastical
legal thrillers mostly.
The most recent book
was "Last First Snow,"
and I am also the lead
writer for the "Bookburners"
serial for Serial Box, which
I am very excited about.
And I also write on
Lindsey's serial,
so I will now pass
it along to Lindsey.
LINDSAY SMITH: My
name is Lindsay Smith,
and I'm the author of several
different YA espionage
flavored books-- "Secret and
Scandal," which are historical
thrillers, and then
"Dreamstrider," which
is a high fantasy thriller,
also, but for Serial Box,
my project is called "The Witch
who Came in From the Cold,"
or as we're shortening
it to "Cold Witch," just
for hashtag purposes, I think.
And that is an exciting
spy thriller also set
1970s Prague,
where there's magic
and espionage in equal measure.
ELLEN KUSHNER: I'm Ellen
Kushner, and probably
best known for my novel, "Swords
Point" and the three-- two
books that came after it.
I'm writing a third right
now, and my big thing
when I wrote "Swords Point"
was that I wasn't ever
allowed to repeat myself.
I couldn't just
write endless sequels
with the same
characters in them.
So every time I
attack that world--
and I use the term
advisedly-- I try
to take a different viewpoint
or a different style.
I've also written
interconnecting short stories.
So "Tremontaine" has been a
really interesting and fun
departure for me.
When you ask what am
I writing right now,
I should be writing the
fourth "Riverside" novel,
but I'm actually writing
the final episode
to "Tremontaine,"
which takes place
15 years before "Swordspoint."
MAX SALTONSTALL: Awesome.
So this is a different
way of publishing.
What's it like writing in
this serial model for you?
You've all written
traditional novels before.
MAX GLADSTONE: For me it feels
a little bit like homecoming
actually, because
when I was a kid,
I started off doing a lot of
internet forum role playing.
So I was active on Usenet
role playing forums and things
like that, and the
first long form piece
that I ever wrote was this
enormous, sprawling kill all
of the characters that nobody
wants to play anymore epic that
was like 300,000 words
long, and I wrote
over the course of a year when
I really should have been doing
a whole bunch of school, and got
to the end of it, and realized,
oh, that was a lot of fun.
I guess I could do this
maybe for money somehow.
That would be nice,
but that was very much
writing chapters
when I had time,
and then posting them,
and getting feedback
on the chapters,
and then thinking
what I need to do next,
and then doing that.
So coming to Serial
Box, where we
have a sort of
episodic structure,
where, for example,
in "Bookburners," we
have sort of supernatural secret
agents working for the Vatican
running around the world
trying to track down magic
and then sticking it in a
box, and then never looking
in the box, because that
always works really well.
So having a separate story about
them each week, and each story
needed to cohere and get
people really excited,
and then leave them
satisfied, but also excited
for the next one felt
like-- I don't know.
Oh, I've been here before.
This is great.
Let's go.
LINDSAY SMITH: Yeah,
I agree with what Max
is saying about posting online.
I think for writers of
a certain age that's
how we grew our craft,
whether you wrote fan fiction
or serialized stories like this.
Well, I wrote 1000
words today, so I'm
going to put it on the internet.
See what everybody thinks of it.
So you learn how to
build those hooks
and so on to lead into the
next episode, the next chapter,
whatever the case may be.
And that has been
for me the most fun
part of doing the
serialized storytelling--
is we have to plan
it out in advance.
Figure out where all the
different little twists
and turns are going to go.
This is definitely
the project that
made me swear off of
just drafting wildly
out into the void, because
it's so much more fun
to have the roadmap and
know what's coming up next.
And we're getting really
excited for all the twists
and turns that we're
about to execute
on poor, unassuming readers.
ELLEN KUSHNER: Oh, that's
the really fun part.
I want to talk about
that later, but just
to answer your question,
it's like summer camp.
You're hanging out
with your friends,
because the really
important thing for me
is not so much the
serial aspect as the fact
that it's being written by
a bunch of different people
with their strengths,
and their annoying bits,
and their cleverness,
and willingness
to work really hard,
but really it's
almost like you've all
gotten together and gone,
let's put on the show.
And that aspect of
collaboration is
one of the real reasons
I wanted to do this,
because if you're with the right
people, it's just a lot of fun.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So how do
go about planning these?
Because it's not the one
thing you're going to write.
It's you're writing it
over many, many steps.
Do you have a consistent
process that you've
used across the team?
ELLEN KUSHNER: Across
each individual team?
Because what we've found is
that each team is a little bit
different, partly because
of what it is we're writing,
and partly because
personalities may vary.
And also we try to all go
like, oh, well Max has already
done "Bookburners," and
I know how they did it,
so we'll do it that way,
and found quite a few bumps
in the road that way that
we've had to-- thank you.
I thought it was just us.
MAX GLADSTONE: I do.
That was your first mistake.
ELLEN KUSHNER: But
it works for you.
And have you been told,
oh, don't do that.
"Tremontaine" tried that.
It was a disaster.
Why don't you it
like "Tremontaine?"
Here's what they do.
What's your experience been?
LINDSAY SMITH: Well
for me, for "The Witch
Who Came in From the Cold,"
we brought everyone together
for what we called
a story summit.
So it's myself, Max, and then
two other writers, Cassie
Claire-- Cassandra Clarke.
I'm sorry.
Cassie Clarke.
Wrong name.
And Ian Tregillis, who are
also really outstanding
fantasy writers, and we
just kind of tossed out
ideas for different types of
episodes we wanted to have.
People had really keyed
in on certain characters
in the series bible that we
had put together beforehand.
There's this one
character-- I think
everybody's going to love her.
She's really sinister,
and fun, and awesome.
So everybody wanted to write an
episode from her point of view,
so it was kind of like fighting
over who gets to do what, when.
ELLEN KUSHNER: We did that, too.
LINDSAY SMITH: Have a
character to fight over?
ELLEN KUSHNER: Same character.
Yeah.
No, the awesome
sinister one, yeah.
LINDSAY SMITH: But then
we took all these ideas
and had them on
these note cards,
and we just kind of
slowly shaped them
into an arc that would
work for an entire season.
And just kind of using
basic story structure,
figured out what peaks and
valleys we wanted that to take
and where the different
points that we'd come up with
would fit along that
larger season long scale.
And eventually it grew
into 13 discrete episodes
that we divided up
amongst ourselves.
ELLEN KUSHNER: Oh,
that's interesting.
So you had the whole
thing, and then you
chopped it into episodes?
LINDSAY SMITH: Yeah.
ELLEN KUSHNER: Because we were
very like episode, episode,
episode.
LINDSAY SMITH: Yeah,
well for the witch series
it's very much-- it's
a lot less episodic.
It's more kind of like
an HBO drama or something
where the episodes kind
of flow into each other,
even though there's a
finite point for each.
ELLEN KUSHNER: You know what?
I'm totally lying.
Totally lying.
What we did was we
had this giant arc,
but it was pretty nebulous, and
then we would sort of go, OK,
in order to make
giant arc work, it's
going be this, this, and this.
MAX GLADSTONE: So
for "Bookburners,"
when the time came to plan
out the actual season,
there were a lot of empty
spaces still in the outline,
because we knew overall
what story we wanted
to tell for the entire
season, but it's
a very episodic structure.
Basically each week--
MAX SALTONSTALL: "X-Files."
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah,
"X-Files," exactly.
Each week something weird
is going on in Denmark,
and we need to go out
and investigate what,
and it might not be in Denmark.
Sometimes it is.
ELLEN KUSHNER: But
it's always rotten.
MAX GLADSTONE: But it's
always rotten, right.
So because of that,
we needed a number
of episodes that just kind of
worked along that model, where
there was a monster of the
week, or there was something
that we needed to go do where we
were basically giving a holding
beat for character development,
if that makes any sense.
So there were episodes
where it was really clear
that characters
needed to transition,
and to grow, and develop, and
then there were episodes where
the current stressor
was on the team
as a whole trying to figure out
the solution to some problem,
which then allowed us to
hold up the different facets
of the team to the light and
see how they were handling
particular sorts of
stress and response.
Because of that, we
have these 16 episodes,
and there were some that
were very pivotal plot
episodes where we knew
exactly what we needed to do,
and there were a lot
that were like, oh,
and then we'll figure
out something later,
and it'll be really cool.
And that worked pretty well.
Well, it allowed actually for
a lot of generative experience
while we were running
through the serial.
So during the first flight
of episodes, basically
each writer on the team--
myself, Margaret Dunlap,
Mur Lafferty, and Brian
Francis Slattery--
all wrote one episode,
and then we had four.
We were looking at
them, and then there
were some natural
outgrowths from there
that we could weave into
the overall series arc
that we were working on.
I think for all of
the teams that I've
been on there's been
this sort of moment
of trying to figure out
a creative vocabulary,
or a common creative
vocabulary for putting together
characters and story lines.
For the "Bookburners"
team, it really
was tabletop role playing.
Once we all-- we were
all coming in from very
different artistic philosophies,
very different writing styles,
but once we figured out
that we'd all gamed before,
we could be like,
OK, let's think
of these as fake characters, and
let's flop them up on the board
and get some aspects.
Once we have that
together, then we
have enough of a story engine
that we can build it out
into a long term thing.
LINDSAY SMITH:
That's interesting
that you say that you really
focused on the characters,
and statting them
out, and so on,
because I feel like for
"Witch" our main drive
was kind of getting
the aesthetic down
for what we wanted.
We wanted the foggy,
cold Prague city streets.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That
visual comes out really
quickly when you
start reading it.
LINDSAY SMITH: Oh, great.
The trench coats, and
the cigarette smoke,
and everything.
MAX SALTONSTALL: It feels cold.
I want a coat when
I'm reading that book.
LINDSAY SMITH: And we talked
a lot about our favorite spy
novels, and television
shows, and everything, too,
to just kind of key
in on what those
aesthetic-- those
feelings, and vibes,
and tropes that we
wanted to twist and toy
with a little bit,
but of course,
bringing in the magic element
as well with a lot of fun.
ELLEN KUSHNER: And
with "Tremontaine"
we were in a really different
place, because the novels
already exist.
So the first trick
was to find writers
who could write in
that world comfortably,
and for that, I kind of
needed to know that they knew
and loved the books,
but then we also wanted
to expand and do
something that I didn't
do when I was 25 years old.
So we got Alaya Dawn Johnson,
who not only likes my books,
but I think it's also
important-- loves
all the same books I do.
So the influences are
going to the same.
We're both riffing
on the same thing,
and she's also been
studying in Mexico,
so we brought in this
whole aspect of a culture
that I had never messed with
by having them be traders who
were importing stuff
into this extremely
cod, European-ish city.
So that's been
exciting, and then
Malinda Lo, who's
primarily written in YA
and is really famous for
having done the first queer
Cinderella for YA.
So we knew she was
going to fit in,
and then since there's a lot of
boy on boy action in my books,
we said, why don't we
get an actual gay man?
So we got Joel Derfner, who
is a famous for gay haiku
and for "Swish."
And he's done mostly
memoir, but I've
been working with him
on a mystery novel,
so I know he can
write the living
hell out of period stuff, and
he also just makes us all laugh.
We can get pretty heated,
and Joel will always
break the tension by saying
something either incredibly
wise or incredibly silly.
And then our show-runner
and her partner wanted in,
and they had a great
episode, which actually just
came out this morning.
And we also brought in a
guest writer, Paul Witcover,
who is not only a
really good writer,
but is the only reviewer who
ever truly understood me.
So I fought hard for Paul.
So this is our little gang.
I actually did a piece
about this for tor.com,
because it's kind of
like "Seven Samurai."
Put together your
people, each of whom
has a different strength,
and it's just crazy.
You see them all
in a room and go,
well, this is going
to be interesting,
and it's just been splendid.
I know I'm talking a lot about
backgrounds and personalities,
but for us-- and
also had to play
well with others,
because this was really
such a weird collaboration with
me in this odd power position,
but I realize that,
since I'm only
writing the pilot
and the series end,
it was really going to be
their world and their stuff.
So I had to go, what?
No.
You can't rent a carriage.
Useful things like that,
but let them really
engage with and create
the new characters
and make them their own.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So you're all
giving up a lot more narrative
control than in your
previous setting.
What's that like through
both managing the team,
but then trying to let go
more than you're used to?
LINDSAY SMITH: I
actually love it,
because I feel like having the
four people just completely
amplifies the creative
power on the team,
and I love seeing people
come up with ideas I never
would have thought of no
matter how much time I
had to work on it.
And it's just
fascinating, because I
would be thinking of just these
silly fixes to plot problems,
and someone would come out
completely out of left field,
and, oh, it's so much better.
I love that so
much, but then being
able to have that
voice of series control
where I just say, all
right, this doesn't quite
fit this characterization,
or I don't think this
would actually happen.
The CA would not stand for
this-- something like that
in the plot and so on.
It's good to have someone
who can direct the ship,
but just letting everyone
run wild with the creativity
is so cool.
I really love seeing
that come together.
MAX GLADSTONE: There's an
aspect of crowd surfing to it.
Everybody's crowd surfing
on everybody else,
and then we get into a
weird topological state.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
It's like everyone
is sitting on each other's
knees [INAUDIBLE] falls over.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah, somehow.
And it's a lot of fun.
The hardest part
for me, actually,
wasn't the world building
or the creative aspects.
I really enjoy running with
stuff that other people do.
Yeah, that looks a little weird.
Let's push it more and see
what happens, but was honestly
it's voice and language related.
I spend a lot of time polishing
the work that I put out,
just the books that I
publish, and draft, and draft,
and draft, and draft to the
point of real obsession.
And realizing when I was going
into other people's episodes
that, OK, this is
somebody who's not me,
they have their own style,
they have their own work,
they have their own rhythm.
You need to figure out how to
respect that and then also make
sure that all the
series is speaking
with almost the same voice.
MAX SALTONSTALL: But they're
writing the same characters.
MAX GLADSTONE: They're writing
the same characters, yeah.
MAX SALTONSTALL: And you don't
want those to sound weird.
MAX GLADSTONE: Well, I don't
want them to sound weird,
but the characters
are actually--
I don't want to say easy, but
once you build these people,
they're sort of live
in everyone's heads.
And it's interesting to see
different people's takes
on them, but I think for all of
us who sat in the story summit
and were really getting into the
architecture of each character,
we understand them well
enough [INAUDIBLE].
ELLEN KUSHNER: Have you also
gotten these weird moments
of synchronicity
where you realize
that people are writing--
they're all writing
at the same time things
about the character
that they couldn't
have talked about,
but that are nonetheless true.
LINDSAY SMITH: Yes.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah,
yeah, absolutely.
ELLEN KUSHNER: It happens.
There's a whole thread of
sympathy with a character who
is supposed to be kind
of bad, but everybody
got that moment of pain
for-- I'll say-- them,
and made it run
beautifully, and they
couldn't have worked it out.
They just knew.
When you're talking about
lots of different people
writing the same voice, we
had that little experiment
in audio.
I know you, Max, have the
amazing woman of a 1000
voices, Xe Sands, reading
everything and everybody,
but we thought,
oh, let's push out
the boat a little
on "Tremontaine,"
and there have been audio books
of the other books already.
Let's get some of the same
actors who worked on them.
So we took three major
viewpoint characters,
and we have three fantastic
audio book readers.
And I thought, oh,
that'll be great.
And I kind naively
didn't realize
that they were all going to
have to sound like each other.
LINDSAY SMITH: Oh,
that's interesting.
ELLEN KUSHNER:
It's a lot of work,
considering we also have someone
with a foreign accent, which
we invented.
So they all had to memorize the
same made up, foreign accent.
LINDSAY SMITH: Oh, wow.
ELLEN KUSHNER: [INAUDIBLE].
MAX SALTONSTALL: You like
to do things the easy way.
ELLEN KUSHNER: Yeah.
No, I just-- but this is
the way I kind of live
my entire creative life,
which is, oh, it'll be fun.
It'll be easy, and
then fortunately
work with good people who
can then deal with when
it turns out not to be easy.
So that's been an
amazing experience.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I think that's
the first audio book I've
listened to, because I'm
listening to your series,
and those different
voices actually really
effectively bring me to
different parts of the world.
And I haven't gotten, I
think, to the confluence yet,
and I'm curious to see
now how that resolves.
I want to hear more
about this writer summit.
You keep alluding to it.
LINDSAY SMITH: Oh gosh,
it was really cool.
Just being able to--
MAX SALTONSTALL: What was it?
LINDSAY SMITH: It was
we all came together
at Julian's apartment
for an extended weekend
to just brainstorm season one
for "The Witch Who Came in
From the Cold" and just
figure out what on earth
are we going to do.
We all have the series bible
in front of us that's got--
MAX SALTONSTALL: You had
written that in advance?
LINDSAY SMITH: I had
written the series bible
that outlined all
the major characters
and how they related both
to the world around them
and to each other.
MAX SALTONSTALL: With
the Venn diagram?
LINDSAY SMITH: Yes,
we've got-- so here's
the really confusing part-- is
we've got KGB and CIA spies all
hanging out in
Prague, but then there
are also two factions
of magic users,
as well-- the Consortium of Ice
and then the Acolytes of Flame.
And so there might
be a CIA person
who's Flame, a CIA person
who's Ice, KGB who's
Flame, KGB who's Ice.
So there's a whole lot of
different alliances at play
here.
So that made it
nice and confusing
to start right off the bat, but
it's really worked out nicely,
but the series
bible laid all that
out-- all the information
about the characters
and what these different
organizations represent.
And then also because it
was a historical series,
I did a lot of work on just
like outlining the time period,
and I had experience with
that from my historical novels
that I'd written set
in the '60s, as well.
So focusing on
what sort of songs
might they hear on the radio,
or what hot gossip might they
be talking about their
favorite movie actors,
whatever the case may be, just
to give that nice background
touch.
So we had all that before
us, but we didn't really
have an overarching
plot, and so it was just
these four writers in a
room tossing out these ideas
and shaping it into
something story-like.
And once we had it
all hammered out,
I really don't think we
deviated from it hardly
at all in terms of here
are the major notes we need
to hit within each episode,
and it's really great
to have that structure.
I come from a place
where I used to draft
without any clear outline.
I just knew a couple things I
wanted to happened somewhere
down the road in the story.
I'm a convert now to
planning in advance,
and it's also really
helped us deconflict
when we have the questions
of, now wait a minute,
would this character do this?
Is this going to line
up well for what's
going to happen three
episodes down the road?
And so it allows us to
avoid the big, big conflicts
that we could have there.
I love having that roadmap,
though, for the story.
MAX GLADSTONE: I'm
so glad to hear
you say that, because working on
both "Witch" and "Bookburners,"
at this point, I'm now a note
card and permanent marker
addict.
LINDSAY SMITH: Yes.
MAX GLADSTONE: There's so
much fun and freedom that
happens when I kind of
know where I'm going,
and then I get to
decide how I want
to attack a particular
scene knowing
what's already going happen.
It's fun.
LINDSAY SMITH: In a way,
it's almost more creatively
freeing to have this
structure in place
that I don't have to think
about while I'm writing.
To already have that brain work
done so that my brain can just
focus on the language,
and the tension,
and so on, I actually
think it helps.
It makes for more creative
writing, rather than
constrictive.
ELLEN KUSHNER: I've never
written so fast in my life.
It's so fun, but just to
make it clear we all start
with the three day total thing.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Bring the
whole writing team together.
ELLEN KUSHNER: Yeah,
we all get together.
In my case, it's
been my living room.
And also food-- critical.
We just basically eat
nonstop the whole time,
because you cannot think without
infusions of blood sugar,
and because-- so Julian kept
us supplied with bagels,
and by the end we were just
main lining chocolate bars.
We could not have come up
with a title for the show
without the chocolate bars.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I'll
come to the next one.
It sounds like it was fun.
ELLEN KUSHNER: No, no, no.
You can't, because you
can't read the thing
with all the cards on it.
And then also in all
my novels there's
a big thing where everybody
drinks chocolate instead of tea
or coffee, and I
thought I've got
it very clear in my head
what the chocolate is like.
It's like coffee in
that you drink it black,
and it can be quite bitter.
So I decided to make
it for the group
so that when they walked in they
would be served hot chocolate,
and actually managed to do it.
And those who wished
could add cream and sugar,
but we were so
high, because I kept
putting out more chocolate.
[LAUGHTER]
The entire weekend, but that
was historical research.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
And then at the end,
everyone gets paid
in chocolate, right?
ELLEN KUSHNER: Oh, yeah.
So we all did the
exact same thing,
and I also want to point
out that our show runner
and writer, Racheline
Maltese, did
this up as a blog post
that's on our blog that talks
about the process a lot more
clearly than I know I am,
because it really is interesting
that it recapitulates
television in that you're
in the white room together,
but only for three
days, and then everyone
goes back to Mexico, or
Los Angeles, or wherever.
And you're left with--
thank god for Google Chat,
and you're not paying me to say
that, but it really is true.
All your other meetings are
when everyone's time zone can
fit together, and their
schedules can fit together,
and we can talk on a screen,
or we chat a lot on Slack,
I guess, we use.
But it is a funny mixture
of that real intimacy
and everybody being in a room,
and then suddenly you're not,
and you still have to
work out those problems.
MAX GLADSTONE: You
have to be thinking
about while you're writing, what
would Brian say about this bit?
ELLEN KUSHNER: Or a quick note
to somebody, occasionally even
texting them going, I know
this is really irritating,
but I've got to
ask you this thing.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah, absolutely.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Did you
guys use a similar process
on "Bookburners" for the--
MAX GLADSTONE: Something
a little similar.
We went into the story
summit with much less
of an idea of what we were
doing than either "Tremontaine"
or "Witch."
LINDSAY SMITH: The guinea pigs.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah,
well we didn't really
know what we needed.
ELLEN KUSHNER: You
were inventing it.
MAX GLADSTONE: We'll
figure it all out.
ELLEN KUSHNER: You invented it.
MAX GLADSTONE: Exactly.
We're just going to
build the raft as we're
trying to sail down the river.
I guess rafts have
sails-- some rafts.
So I'd written up a brief pitch
document for "Bookburners"
outlining the concept, a few
basic characters, and then
we'd passed it around to
all of the different writers
and people who were interested
or involved in the project.
So it accumulated edits
and edits after that,
and then track changes
things, and then
comments in the margins.
Then margin comments
on the comments that
were in the margins originally.
So by the end, we had this
sort of everlasting gob stopper
of a sort of show
document, and we all
sat in my living
room thinking, OK,
so what's actually
true after all of this?
And everyone had
issues with what
had been contributed so far
ranging from some characters
seemed way too flat
or sort of shadowy.
We had, I think, first
a two or three hour long
conversation about the thematics
of the world and the set
up, because some of us were
more or less comfortable
with the notion of,
OK, so you're trying
to grab magic and put it away.
Is that censorship?
Is that taking care of
dangerous atomic materials?
What's the dominant
narrative here,
and what do people
think about it?
And once we dialed in
enough on that question,
we realized that that was
sort of the issue at the heart
of all of the characters.
We're dealing with
something that is dangerous,
that is complicated.
Everyone has a dramatically
different opinion about it.
different relationship to it.
So that's where the
conflict is going
to come from inside the team.
What's going to stop or
enable all of these people
to come together?
Then the comfort
outside of the team
is stuff trying to eat them
usually, so that's nice.
And from there, we
basically boiled
the characters
back to the barest
outlines, and started building
them up, and saying, OK,
how do these people connect
with this thematic structure.
Where are they going?
What do they want?
And some folks ended up
entirely changing roles,
and backgrounds, and
personalities in this process.
And then we had to
build up who they
were once that had happened,
but the first couple days
were all taken care of.
In some ways, the
serious bible stuff
had already existed
for "Tremontaine"
and had already
existed for "Witch."
Once that was done, though,
everyone was very much on board
with what had happened,
because they'd all
had hands on the clay,
and then story structure
could be much more
fluid, and we all
had a common sense of the truth.
So when someone says
this doesn't actually
sound like Liam, or this
isn't quite Sal's thing, then,
oh yeah, OK, yes.
I remember that.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's cool.
It sounds like a fascinating
brainstorming session
that kicked off all of these.
In my experience,
facilitating a good brainstorm
is actually really challenging.
So what did you do?
You don't just want
to throw people
in a room with
bagels and chocolate
and say go make a book, right?
How did you actually
structure it, if at all?
Or what, in retrospect,
worked really nicely
to get everybody working
towards something together?
LINDSAY SMITH: What
we started out with
was we wanted everyone
to come to the story
summit with an episode
already ready to pitch.
This is a thing
that I would like
to see happen in this season.
Most of those ended up
changing a little bit,
but it was really a
good starting point
to know we've already got
these dots that we can
connect as we shape the season.
MAX SALTONSTALL: And
that'll be after they've
read the story bible to know--
LINDSAY SMITH: After
they're read the bible.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So you've
set down the context, and then
bringing a pitch?
LINDSAY SMITH: Right.
Right, so we're all working
with the same language
for the story, and we've got
that fluency for the series,
and from there, we
can start reshaping.
How do we want the story
to actually progress?
This is the starting
point in the series bible.
Where do we want to go with it?
So that's kind of
what we focused on,
and everybody had their episode
ideas, and then we also--
because our focus is on both
espionage and witchcraft,
we had everybody come up with
a magical item, or spell,
or element that they wanted to
see come to life in the story.
So that kind of
gave us a MacGuffin
to work with in the
different episodes, as well.
I forget the rest
of the question.
MAX SALTONSTALL: How to
structure the brainstorming so
that but it's not
just a bunch of people
all hollering at a white board,
but it's something useful.
LINDSAY SMITH: It was
almost like watching
like fractals
diffuse or something.
We started out with these
really big blobs of ideas,
and as we made it
into a larger arc,
and then into
individual episodes,
that's when it got these finer
levels of granularity, I guess,
is a good way to put it.
We just kind of shaped
it down into an episode.
All right, here's what
this slice of time
looks like, and then here are
the three acts of that episode,
or here are the little bullet
points for that episode.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Did you
first collaboratively make
that whole arc so that you
could then carve it up?
LINDSAY SMITH: Yes, and that's
where the note cards really
came into place.
We had this nice
big bulletin board
that we were sticking
things to, and we got them
in the right order, and then
we broke them down further.
It really worked out
nicely to just branch down
into the individual story beats.
MAX GLADSTONE: Two aspects
of both of the summits
that was involved in that
were huge-- there was a time
structure that we
imposed on everything.
This is Margaret
Dunlap's notion.
I think this is coming off
of the way [INAUDIBLE].
MAX SALTONSTALL: She's
worked in television.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah, she's
worked in television,
and she was choosing "The
Middleman" writer's room,
and she has a sense
of breaking time up
into 45 minute increments.
You have 45 minutes on, and
then 12 minutes off basically.
It was in the 45 you
consider yourself
to be in a Faraday cage.
Phones are down.
Computers are off.
There's nothing going
on except for focusing
on this particular story issue.
Nobody leaves.
Nobody does anything.
Then 12 minutes where you can
just go, and catch breath,
and do whatever you
need to do, and then
come back for the next 45.
And that really helped,
I think, make sure
that everybody was 100% involved
in solving the questions that
really needed to be solved.
And also I think the focused
story summit aspect of it--
the fact that we were only there
for three or four days-- really
added a bit of fire.
You know that you need to
get everything done or most
everything done
within that time.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Did you know what
you needed to get done
in those three days?
MAX GLADSTONE: Well we knew
that after those three days
we were not going to
be co-located probably
until the next one unless
something very strange
happened.
So anything that involved us
talking to one another really
needed to be finished in those
three days, and going in we
knew that what we
hoped to get out of it
was a plan for the series, an
episode by episode breakdown,
and episode assignments,
and then a sense of who
the characters were, because
once we had the episode
timeline and a good
sense of the characters,
the rest can kind of
take care of itself.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Ellen, you perhaps got
the biggest story bible
going into that brainstorming
session, right?
ELLEN KUSHNER: Oh lordy, yeah.
MAX SALTONSTALL: How
did you structure it
so people could contribute?
ELLEN KUSHNER: Well, we
really do the same thing
that everybody else
did, and I was not
the leader, which was a good
thing, because that left
me free to make chocolate and
wave my hands going no, no, no,
or yes, yes, yes.
So Julian Yap, who
is our publisher--
we were actually supposed
to have Margaret Dunlap, who
is a television person, and
she was snowed in, in March.
Good old New York City.
And so Julian stepped
in, and he went,
OK, I'm going to try and
do what Margaret did,
but I don't know if I can
do it, and he was brilliant.
He was fantastic, any
he was the team leader,
and kept us all more
or less on track,
and also knew when to shut
up and just let us get wild.
And we did-- that 45 minute
thing was absolutely brilliant,
but you really felt that
things were taking off
when the timer would go off,
and first of all, you wouldn't
believe it had been 45 minutes.
It felt like 12, and
then nobody wanted
to stop because we were right
in the middle of this really
great idea.
It was very interesting
to watch how that worked,
but we basically knew
what the ending needed
to be of the three days and just
let him guide us through it.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Cool.
So releasing in this format,
you have a different way
of engaging with your
readers and your friends.
So have you found that
that sort of community
has evolved differently
now that you've
got this different style
of putting it out there,
or is it similar to other
books that you've written?
MAX GLADSTONE: That's been
the hardest part for me,
honestly, because I'm not having
done a lot of publicity stuff
before I started
publishing books.
My norms were set
by novel publishing.
So here's a thing.
I took nine months to write it.
It's out there now.
I'm going to spend
a month basically
not shutting up about it
ever and running around
like mad trying to shove
it in people's hands.
Read my book.
And then I go back
into my cave and don't
talk to anyone for a long
time-- another nine months
as I'm writing another book.
And this way, having something
coming out every week,
I can't do that.
I can't do the
always on publicity
push that I do post novel
launch, because that would,
for one thing,
exhaust the community,
and for another thing, I
would be a pile of jello.
So finding a good pace for
that has been really hard.
I'm really impressed, honestly,
with how Ellen's done it.
You seem to have a
fantastic mix going on.
ELLEN KUSHNER: Yeah,
it's a little weird.
I just love it, and I
was told a while ago
that I had a really good
connection with my readers
and had been
encouraged to do this.
I probably spend too much
time connecting and stuff,
but the thing that I've learned
after promoting a ton of things
over the last few
years is, just when
you think you've
completely saturated
and everyone is sick of
it, a month later you'll
get somebody going, oh, you
mean there's an audio book?
Come on.
I did nothing but talk
about it for 90 days.
So you can't ever stop really.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Yeah, fair enough.
ELLEN KUSHNER: But you have to.
You really have to.
LINDSAY SMITH: "Witch"
hasn't come out yet.
It doesn't have
until January 13,
I believe, but I'm really
excited to get-- in publishing
terms, at least-- what we would
consider immediate feedback
on our stories, because
I think at this point
every single one of the books
that I've published so far
it was about three
years between the time
I started writing it to
the time it was on shelves.
So it'll be really
nice to have what
feels like all this
instantaneous comments
on it from readers and
hearing people connecting
with the story, and I think
it's going to be really
cool because I remember this
myself as somebody who's
a fan of television
shows and so on.
Oh my gosh, let's talk about
what happened this week,
and getting really into
it, and theorizing.
I can't wait to just
be the fly on the wall
for the online discussion for
how that's going to play out.
ELLEN KUSHNER: That
is the best part.
I am telling you.
If for nothing else, for
that experience in forever,
you are essentially
reading the novel
over somebody else's shoulder.
When the reviews
start coming in,
they are more like
recaps than reviews,
because it's a short piece, and
people want to talk about it.
And you watch them guessing
what's going to happen,
and loving, and then
hating, or hating
and then loving characters.
Oh, it's such crack.
One of the interesting
things about this
that we haven't
talked about that much
is how we have to set our
brains to thinking like TV,
but being book people.
The one, I think,
piece of vocabulary
that we've all
learned to share is
don't talk about it as a novel.
Talk about it as a series,
and they're not stories.
They're episodes.
And you really have
to think that way,
or you will get a
little nuts, and it also
keeps a big group of
people from going off
in all directions
when you think,
I'm writing the
episode in which.
So the pay off for
that in a way is
getting to watch people
engage as if it were a TV
episode, but secretly
thinking, god,
it's like I'm reading my
book over their shoulder.
It's just a lovely
fusion of the two.
LINDSAY SMITH: And I
think what the great thing
about the episodes, too,
is, even though you talked
about how we have to all make
sure the characters all sound
the same, there's a
continuity of story,
each episode you
really do you feel
the writer who wrote it, too.
We've got Cassandra Rose Clarke.
She's got this great witty
dialogue that she does.
Ian Tregillis has these really
wonderful Baroque descriptions
of things that are
really engrossing.
So each episode, even though you
feel the overarching continuity
of it, you can
tell who wrote it,
and it's really, really cool
to see that all coming together
into this beautiful patchwork.
So I think that's going
to be cool to see how
readers engage with that, too.
MAX GLADSTONE: It's like you get
a different directorial voice
in each episode.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So because you
could pick up just one episode
and then not continue on,
you have this bigger burden
to make people care
right from the start.
So how do you do that?
LINDSAY SMITH: Great question.
I'll find out in
a month, I guess.
MAX GLADSTONE: I
think not hiding
the ball becomes a
lot more important
in the episodic structure than
it is in novel length prose
fiction.
So it's showing people what
they're getting themselves
in for almost as
soon as possible.
So in "Bookburners,"
basically the first scene
you know demons are
possessing people,
and things are getting
shoved into walls,
and magicky stuff is
happening, and people
are bleeding from their eye
sockets, and it's great.
If you get there and
you're like, oh yes, I
want more of this, this is
good, because we have more of it
to provide to you.
And similarly, I think
we start off "Witch"
with this very strong hit of
what's going on in the series.
LINDSAY SMITH: Yeah, we
wanted to make it very clear
up front that there's
spy craft in here,
but there's also
witchcraft going on.
And I think the first episode
really strikes a nice balance
for setting up these two
different woven together type
of themes.
MAX SALTONSTALL: And how
they interact in that world.
LINDSAY SMITH: Yes, because
I think the very first scene
starts out these spies
who are on this look out,
and they're very clearly spies,
and they're using espionage
terminology, but by the
end of that first scene,
I think you realize that
there's something paranormal
or supernatural
going on as well.
I think as soon as we make
that clear to the readers
I think they'll
be like, OK, yes.
This is what I'm here for.
I'm set.
MAX SALTONSTALL: They're
pretty explicit about hunting
a golem [INAUDIBLE].
Not the usual run of the mill.
ELLEN KUSHNER: I actually
had to learn to do that.
It was very interesting.
We had the meeting, and
that night I sat down
and started writing the pilot.
And I thought, this is great.
I'm going to introduce each
of the major characters,
and each of them will
be looking at the city.
And that way I'll
introduce the city
from all these different
viewpoints to everybody,
and just make it
all very delicious,
and write scenes
with witty dialogue,
and have them going
to the next place
that they're clearly going to
be so that next week you'll
want to see them there.
And I turned it
in with great joy
and was told by pretty
much everybody, Ellen,
this is really fun
to read, but it
reads like the first
chapter of a novel.
You've got your characters.
You've got your setting,
but where's the tension?
I'm like, well, the
tension is that you
care about my
characters, and you
want to know what's going
to happen to them next.
And I sat down, and
took a few breaths,
and waited for the
next few episodes
to come in, because
what we kept finding
was that little jewels would
turn up that nobody had thought
of during the meeting, or
that little extra Phillips
and curlicues would be
added, which were going
to need to be planted earlier.
So I actually refused to
rewrite it until we had,
I think, four more
episodes done.
Then I read them all
and went, right, got it.
Went back in and figured out
the two strands of tension
that I could
legitimately work in
right now that would
have pay off later,
and turned it in, and
was perfectly happy,
and was blissfully
unaware of how
absolutely critical it was
that readers read it and want
to go on, because I'd been very
much thinking about my fans
would all want to read
this, because they're
big followers of the world.
And with any luck some
new people would come in.
Almost all of the reviews
and things I've seen
and the jumping up and
down is from people
who had never heard of me.
And so the stakes were
higher than I realized
to make them love my world,
and what we were going
to do with it, and my people.
So I'm still kind
of fanning myself
on the couch with the smelling
salts about, thank god,
I didn't quite understand
how important that
was, and thank god it worked.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Or you could
just put it down, right?
You won't pick up a book as
easy as just one episode.
The first one is
free, and I don't even
like your first character.
She's kind of atrocious.
ELLEN KUSHNER: Oh, yeah.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Which is intentional,
but immediately it's an
interesting journey of, OK, now
I've got this second
set of characters,
and then this third
and who do I want to
latch onto, because I
don't want to care about her.
She's mean.
ELLEN KUSHNER: And
one of my hallmarks
with all my characters always
is I love to flip expectation.
So there are all
sorts of things you
think you know that are going to
turn out to be different later,
so hang in there.
Don't give up.
MAX SALTONSTALL: OK, OK.
I'll keep going.
So what does a
part two look like?
What is a next sequel or a
series in a serial format
feel like or behave
like as an author?
LINDSAY SMITH: Have
you actually started
on season two work
for "Bookburners" yet?
MAX GLADSTONE: We
have, actually.
LINDSAY SMITH: Awesome.
MAX GLADSTONE: So it's
been a lot of fun.
So the first
exposure to any world
or any group of
characters you're
doing a lot of exploration.
You're setting
boundaries where what
is possible in
this world, what is
possible for these characters?
And then you bring
them to a crisis moment
in which a few more of those
questions get answered.
That means that the next step
is exploding those boundaries
or warping them
somehow, figuring out
what of the underlying
truths of the first season
you're going to start
shifting and changing.
So the climax of the first
season of "Bookburners"
is pretty society shaking,
and all the characters
are kind of reeling
from that at the end
and are pushing into
changes that they
want to make in the world,
and the way they do business,
and the way they
interact with magic.
And that is the engine,
because that creates conflict
among the characters, between
the characters and the society
that they're a part of,
and between the characters
and the writer world.
So the first season is
about-- or the first book
is often about characters
exploring the world,
and then the second one is
actually trying to change it.
LINDSAY SMITH: I like that.
I like that a lot.
For me, it feels
a lot like writing
any sequel where you want to
give people more of the same,
but different.
So have them feel like they're
still in the same universe,
but the stakes have changed
and that the characters have
been irrevocably
changed by whatever
catastrophic thing happened
at the end of season one,
because that's how it
always happens, right?
So I think what
we're going to need
to look at is where our end
game is for the whole series.
And now that we've
had our fun playing
in this exciting new
playground in season one
our characters finally
understand their place
in the world, like
you were saying,
and what they want
to get out of it now.
So we need to look
both at where we're
going for the end of the season
and for the end of the series
way out off in the distance, and
start making things even more
complicated, or looking
for new little twists
to bring in that explore
themes that we haven't gotten
to touch on yet in season one.
For me, that's what
a series is about--
is looking at all the different
permutations within the world
and how you can make them add
up into horrible and exciting
things.
ELLEN KUSHNER: And
again, I started off
thinking like a book person,
and as episode 9 and 10 came in,
and I knew I was going to have
to start writing the season
finale, my initial
response was, oh, well,
let's just kill them all.
Then we can start over
with more fun toys.
I'm done with these toys.
I played with
these toys already.
And gently told no, in TV
you don't do [INAUDIBLE].
You have to keep them
and have them become
different in the next series.
So fortunately, by the time now
that I've read 11 and 12 and I
see the possibilities, and I
sat down and started writing--
and again, I was like, but I
cannot take this responsibility
upon myself We have to have
another giant meeting to decide
what season two will be
like so that I can set it up
in the 13th episode.
It's like, no, no.
It's OK.
Just go.
And damn it, the muse
comes down and goes,
you can have some fun with this.
And what I found
myself doing just
instinctively without planning--
because no one would let
me plan for this.
No one would enable
me to plan-- was
that there are
secondary characters who
are going to become really
important in the next season,
and suddenly I
found myself writing
from their point of view, which
is my secret way of telling you
that you are now going to
be following this person
and taking an interest
in them, and I needed
a minor, minor, minor character,
the nurse to somebody who's
sick, and suddenly she
came to me full blown.
And I realized that she's
really interesting seeing,
and so now she's
running in my head.
And there are characters
that people just love.
The thing that I'm just
starting to be able to get-- we
just posted episode five,
and I'm writing episode 13,
but I know who
people love, and I
know who people are
really worried about.
And while I'm not going to
let that change our decisions,
because we already had the
chocolate and the bagels,
I know what satisfaction
I can give them
by engaging with these
characters in a particular way.
And then we'll have another
giant three day meeting,
I presume, and sort out what
the arc is for next year,
but I was told not only
could I not kill everybody,
but that someone needed
to be happy at the end,
that I couldn't just leave
a trail angst behind me.
So I know who's going
to be happy, too,
and they're very sweet.
LINDSAY SMITH: At
least temporarily.
ELLEN KUSHNER: Oh, yeah.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So as
you're prepping that finale,
what kind of feedback
are you then getting
from the rest of the team.
ELLEN KUSHNER: Nothing.
Oh, well, I-- no, I
shouldn't say this.
No, I'm going to finish
a draft, and I'm late,
but I hope there will be time
for me to send it out to them
and make sure that they're
all comfortable with it
before we can go farther,
including-- we're all messing
with each other's
characters all the time,
and even though technically
we all co-own and co-create
everybody, I very much
have a sense of who brought
what Barbie to the game.
There's no question about that.
Alaya, for instance, is the
god of [INAUDIBLE] and all
of her [INAUDIBLE]
people, and that really we
need to check in with her
before we mess with it,
and that Rafe is
really Joel's man,
and we will check in with him.
That been something we do
that I don't know if you guys
do as much.
We sort of own
characters, again,
like kids just playing
with their dolls,
but I think also at this
point having read and edited
12 episodes I've got
a pretty good idea,
but I do want to
check and make sure
that they're OK with everything.
LINDSAY SMITH: That's a
really interesting point,
because I think we've ended
up writing the POVs of pretty
much all the major characters
over the course of 13 episodes,
but Max and I co-wrote
both the pilot,
and then we're getting ready to
co-write the season finale as
well.
And we both kind of
instinctively gravitated
toward the opposite characters
for the first episode
and the last episode
to write the POVs.
So the main character,
Gabriel, who's
an American CIA
operative, and then Tanya,
a KGB officer who is also
a witch for the Ice--
so I just naturally picked
up on the Russian characters,
because that's kind
of my background--
is writing about Soviet
Russia, and then Max
gravitated toward Gabriel.
It was kind of Max's
invention anyway.
So we just clutched
onto them even
though throughout the
course of the episode
we would obviously write in
all the different personas.
MAX GLADSTONE: It'll be fun
to go back to both of them
and see how the
polarity has shifted.
LINDSAY SMITH: Oh, yeah, it's
going to be very different.
MAX SALTONSTALL: What
about you in terms of--
MAX GLADSTONE: We don't have
a lot of very strict ownership
of anyone.
All the characters are
sort of public property
within the "Bookburners" team.
People who are bringing
specific world building elements
tend to end up more like the
source of truth for that.
So I knew things
about Grace going
in that were sort of important,
and I ended up being, I think,
the final line of yes or
no on decisions with her.
And some people
were more invested
in particular elements of
the magic system, or humor,
or guns, the ongoing
question of when
people are allowed to be
carrying guns in Europe,
for example.
But the characters are all
everybody's property for us.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Cool.
Has your reading
habit changed now
that you've started writing
in this different style?
LINDSAY SMITH: That's
a great question.
I'm definitely reading
a lot more spy thrillers
than I used to.
I've always enjoyed it, but
Ian brought up the Tim Powers
series "Declare," and so on,
so I'm really getting into that
and also trying to read more
about witchcraft and folklore
type spells so we can weave that
in more-- I guess authentically
is the right word.
I don't know, but
something [INAUDIBLE].
MAX GLADSTONE: 100%
authentic witchcraft.
This witchcraft felt very fake.
I continue to read
eclectically and oddly.
You never know what's
going to be useful.
LINDSAY SMITH: Very true.
ELLEN KUSHNER: Although,
I actually-- I guess
I'm reading nonfiction that I
might not otherwise have read.
We have this whole
mathematical navigation,
figuring odds, card
playing plot, which
turned out-- I had no idea.
I had to call my
poker playing friend
to ask how you could count cards
and be a better poker player,
and he said, well, you know,
Descartes invented that.
And my heart skipped a beat,
because that's our plot.
We had basically reinvented
reality, as one does,
and so then I started reading
all about 17th century science
because there was a
great encyclopedia that
explained how it all
worked, because really
to have people inventing science
and mathematics when you don't
really know the history
of it yourself--
fortunately I have a
very good friend who
is a mathematician, who
got the biggest kick out
of being on group calls with
us and giving us advice,
but I just found a book called
"How Paris Became Paris," which
is not about the 19th century,
which is what we all think of.
Haussmann blowing everything up
and making straight beautiful--
the Paris that we know.
Apparently in the
17th century, Paris
became an ultra modern city.
It was like the Tokyo of its
day because they did things
like sidewalks and
outdoor lighting,
and while my city is a
mishmash of everything,
it's very hard for us to
imagine a city where there
is no natural
light-- or excuse me,
no non natural light at night.
And you know that people did
go out at night sometimes,
and you have some vague idea
that there were lanterns.
Well, it turns out
that householders
were responsible
for hanging lights
so that there wouldn't
be as much crime,
and there's just all this
stuff in this wonderful book.
And sometimes it just
confirms something
that you made up that
you hope you can fake,
and it just makes
you feel better,
and sometimes you get
new exciting new ideas.
LINDSAY SMITH: I think
watching television
has changed for me more than
reading, because it's already
got the episodic format.
I was really getting
into in my head
outlining "Jessica Jones"
as I was binging that,
and "Daredevil," and so on.
Paying a lot more
attention to the way
they do the little hooks
at the ends of episodes
and so on to guide
you into the next.
So for me, it's more
paying attention
to craft elements like that.
MAX GLADSTONE: That's
a really good point.
I found myself much
more aware of, oh well,
and here's your act break.
Here are your plot
element changes.
MAX SALTONSTALL: But you're
not going to let me binge read.
[LAUGHTER]
ELLEN KUSHNER: Well, we are.
There are clearly people
who are holding off
until the whole thing is
done so that they binge read.
LINDSAY SMITH: Oh, really?
ELLEN KUSHNER: And that's
frankly what I do with TV.
I can't remember when I
watched something once a week,
so I just wait.
So I have sympathy with people.
MAX GLADSTONE: Having
have now caught up
with "Steven Universe," I am,
for the first time in maybe
a decade, waiting for the next
episode of the television.
I just thought
they were all done,
and then you got the boxed
sets and then watched them.
MAX SALTONSTALL: But now you're
inflicting this exact pain
on your fans, you realize?
MAX GLADSTONE: This is true.
Yeah, I don't know.
We pass it on.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
So you've all taken
interesting cultural collages.
How did you get yourself
into the cultures
that you're borrowing from or
even fabricating to then bring
them into these stories.
MAX GLADSTONE:
Well, "Bookburners"
is pretty straightforward
because it's
operating in something that's
basically the modern world.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
But you're not part
of the Vatican [INAUDIBLE].
MAX GLADSTONE: Well, no.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
As far as I know.
MAX GLADSTONE: No, not at all.
That would be really weird.
MAX SALTONSTALL: It's
the best cover ever.
MAX GLADSTONE: That's
the way I go for it, Max.
So yes.
So the hardest part
was-- and remains--
figuring out what
kind of picture
we could draw of
interior Vatican politics
without either deeply offending
people, which we don't want
to deeply offend
too many people,
or just getting stuff wrong.
And so we're drawing heavily off
of childhood religious history,
and current experience,
and also the notion
that this is a sort of
enormous sprawling bureaucracy,
and many of the writers
who are on the team
have a lot of experience
in one or many of those.
So often for me
trying to write stuff
that I don't have direct
physical or personal experience
with is a question of
I'm talking to as many
people as I can, but then
trying to identify what
in this system corresponds
with something that I do
have direct physical
experience of.
If there's some correspondence
that I can find,
then it kind of breaks
open a little bit,
and it becomes much
easier to navigate,
but there's always the risk
of getting stuff wrong.
LINDSAY SMITH: For
the "Witch" series,
I think we focused
more on making things
feel authentic than accurate.
So what I mean by that is, as
the resident Russian scholar
for the team, I
can kind of step in
and say, I don't
really think they
would make a big deal about
Christmas at this time of year.
I don't think the KGB-- someone
would say this this directly.
There would be a little
more subterfuge about it,
but by the same
token, I can't exactly
go over to Lubyanka,
the KGB headquarters,
and read through their archives,
what hasn't been burned down
in 1993.
So we just try to strive to
hit the right cultural notes
and make it the feel immersive
without being completely
accurate, and
nobody in the story
is necessarily going to
have all the answers either.
People are only going to
be aware of their slice
of the universe at
that time, and the same
went for the witchcraft
elements, too.
One of the other things
we did at the story summit
was figure out how our magic
worked, and we tossed out
a bunch of different
ideas, but we ultimately
settled on a medieval elemental
type magic, a lot of chemical
symbols, and use of
different elements including
herbs, and grasses,
and minerals,
and things of that sort.
So once we laid
down that structure,
even though our spells
probably don't really
work out exactly internally,
logistically-wise, they still
have the right feeling
of a cohesive universe
for the spells, and so on.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Now, you've
taken on a big amalgamation.
ELLEN KUSHNER: You don't really
want me to answer that, do you?
Or do you?
The thing is that I
created the original city,
and the reason I think that
Julian wanted me to do this
as part of Serial Box was that
he said it's just a fun place
to hang out.
And one of things that's been
particularly fun for me-- well
first of all, creating
it-- that it was sort
of every city and culture that
I had read about and really
enjoyed, and I got to mix
them all up in a big stew pot.
So I had Elizabethan London, and
the Regency London of Georgette
Heyer, and a whole lot
of 18th century Paris,
"Liason Dangereuse,"
certain amount
of Damon Runyon
for my low lives,
and my own life in
the '80s in New York
when it was a very dangerous,
and very edgy, and also very
gay city.
And I just put it all
together and had a good time,
and I also am very
aware now since I'm
a New Yorker how much
a city will change
during your own
lifetime, but one
of my complaints
about fantasy novels
is people don't
understand that, if you're
living in a particular
world, you're very conscious
of its changes.
I think if we all went
back to Ancient Greece,
it would all look
the same to us,
but you had-- I can't
remember who it was,
but one of the Greeks
saying, ugh, it's
not like it used to be, and
everything's terrible now.
And so you've got to
assume that people
are hypersensitive
to those changes.
And so one of the things that
we're doing with "Tremontaine"
is quite consciously
setting it at a time
when some of the things
that happen in later books
that everybody's read
aren't happening yet.
It's the prelude to what's been
happening in "Swordspoint,"
and that's been
really interesting,
and then of course, everybody
brings their own strengths
and interests.
One of the things
that I remember
after "Swordspoint" people said,
well there's no middle class.
I'm like, yeah there is.
Just my characters
aren't interested in it.
So we added them
in a later book.
I collaborated on one with
my wife, Delia Sherman,
and just as with New York City,
or Paris, or anywhere else
you go, you're only going
to see certain parts of it,
and you're only going to be
interested in certain parts
of it.
There are other parts we
just haven't been to yet,
and that's really
what "Tremontaine"
has been able to do with
our cast of writers.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Cool.
Well, thank you all very
much for joining us.
I look forward to
the next episode.
LINDSAY SMITH: Thank you.
MAX GLADSTONE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]